[Musique]
je vais vous montrer une vidéo et vous
allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
bah pour moi je vois des gilets jaunes
du coup ça nous savons par la pelouse
les deux ce qui s'est passé pour le prix
de l'essence je n'ai pas fait ça pour
rire parce que je pense pas que ce soit
ça c'est fait exprès c'était pas des
militaires français est en fait ils ceux
des belges étaient en transe port et les
militaires belges et quand ils sont en
transport ils ont toujours des gilets
jaunes mais je pense qu'ils l'ont pas
dit pour montrer que si les militaires
sont contre les odomètres contre aussi
quelle information pourra te dire que
c'est faux une des personnes incroyables
qui a vu sa passe récemment la
télévision je peux vous assurer que
c'est sûr snapshot donc sur snapshot
peut y avoir plein de fake sur instagram
aujourd'hui on a une petite croix à côté
qui signifie que c'est vraiment le
personnage et non du fait parce qu'elle
sait qu'elle quatre ans comme ermont la
confiance en lui donc on pense et on
espère aussi qui dit pas n'importe quoi
vraiment très bien me faire avoir
parce que vous connaissez la fleur chou
le film non les règles de l'app urgent
c'est s'habille en noir avec un masque
si possible toute personne dehors sera
mêlé frappé toutes les armes seront
légal pendant le
de halloween ils ont dit ça devait se
passer cette nuit là et à plein de gens
qui y ont cru
on a compris mais qui se sont préparés
pour ça et ça vous l'avez tous entendu
surtout sur snapshot je crois c'est là
que c'était le but de plus ça j'imagine
que la purge vous en parler avec tout le
monde
les parents ils se renseignent pas trop
sur l'actualité le monde s'il ya un truc
à savoir c'est vrai vous me demandez
plutôt à moi si moi je suis au courant
[Musique]